[Musique]
le premier point sur lequel j'aurai
envie qu'on avance et ou qu'on va mettre
en place pour le deuxième semestre
il est sur les repas c'est de permettre
à tous les étudiants qu'ils demandent
d'avoir accès aux deux repas par jour
par les restos u à 1 euro et donc ça
veut dire qu'on ouvrirait au nom
boursier tous les cas que vous évoquez
les étudiants étudiants qui ne sont pas
dans la catégorie boursiers n'ont pas
droit aux repas au resto u 1 euro les
étudiants internationaux qui sont aussi
quand même très isolés l'australienne là
et donc on ouvrirait à tous les
étudiants non boursiers et
internationaux qui en font la demande
l'accès aux deux repas qu'on peut aller
prendre au respect rue à 1 euro